The Joe Rogan Experience what sharking
is people think of pool shark as being
someone who's like really good at pool
that's not what we call sharking
sharking for the people that don't know
is like if you're about to shoot and I
moved and distracted you on purpose like
I wait until you write about this to
move and I'll drop my cue yeah or I'll
spill a drink I'll make some noise like
people do things on purpose to try to
distract people yep that happens a lot
that's especially gambling that's some
[ __ ] [ __ ] yep isn't it oh yeah they
tried all the time too but it's some
[ __ ] [ __ ] when someone does that that's
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] like what are you doing
just play oh there's a lot of moves even
when it comes to Pro players too is
there like what uh I don't know I don't
really want to mention names but no you
don't have to mention names so I was
playing the guy a long race last year
and uh
for example everybody knows like uh if
you if you win a cyber plane I'll raise
to 100 and every every day we're playing
on Race to 33. so I I ended up winning
day one
and I should be the one breaking the
balls next day
so uh I come in and we're about to begin
and he's like
are we lagging again
so I'm like uh no bro it's my break
so there was a lot of a lot of different
moves like we used to we agreed to play
with one magic wreck and he ended up
stealing the magic wreck and
then we were on the break and I broke
the balls make four balls on the break
and I had that I was dead out and he's
like are you practicing or what are you
doing I'm like no we're playing I just
asked you a minute ago are you ready to
start and he's like
I didn't say anything uh I was thinking
you're you're Pricks I'm like no this is
a professional who did this yeah I think
you should say his name everybody rhyme
with huh what does his name rhyme with
rhyme with what does it rhyme with
like uh Bogan rhymes with Rogan
uh everybody rhymes with Dillard
everybody will understand he was he was
a Filipino oh okay so
so he was well you know they're probably
gambling a lot of money right uh we
played for 20 grand yeah yeah yeah
a big chunk of money yeah big chunk of
money and people get they get a little
feisty yeah yeah
um in gambling do you think that people
take drugs when they Gamble uh yeah
absolutely look at you like yeah yeah
what do you think they play what do they
think they take Adderall
um uh amphetamines yeah
because you can see if you go to Derby
City Classic you'll see people play for
two three days straight really without
any breaks that's a heart attack special
right there oh yeah it is it is and they
play some crazy games like these aren't
the healthiest people in the world
either that are taking this Adderall and
staying up for days like there are
[ __ ] they're burning it oh yeah it's
unbelievable they play some crazy ass
games like 15 ball band game where you
just it's an old it's an old man game
where you just kind of clip the balls
and you're just banging balls around for
like 50 minutes so it's a bank game yeah
15 balls yeah but there is a lot of
moving part like you just play safety
safety safety until you have a good bank
shot yeah and then after 50 minutes of
playing safeties you have a bank shot
most likely you're gonna miss it and
then it goes over and over and over and
they do it for like days and days
so adderall's the big one it is a big
one uh uh I'm sure people play on
cocaine uh I would think cocaine would
be a problem I've never done cocaine but
from what I understand it doesn't last
that long no but they they're taking
breaks
and I've seen one time I've seen the guy
was using cocaine instead of uh the
powder for his Q what
that's an expensive powder right there
yeah he was putting cocaine on his
fingers yeah and then doing like
oh my God
yeah yeah
cocaine for baby powder oh my God that's
insane but he was he was [ __ ] up like
completely
was he playing well he was playing
decent I mean he's a decent player I
don't know his name but uh he was a just
an action junkie well like I said about
that book uh buddy hall I think it's uh
from rags to Riflemen is the name of the
book I have a copy of it and it's a very
old book and the way it was made it
looks like it was self-published like
the font would be different sizes on
different pages it's a rare book you can
still find it like sometimes on AZ
Billiards someone has a copy of it for
sale but it's pretty valuable now but
they all played on amphetamines and they
would all play for days and days and
days but it [ __ ] a lot of people's
lives up oh of course because they all
got addicted to that stuff of course
yeah I mean I've played a lot of matches
that lasted more than 10 hours and for
me it's it's really really tough because
I never do anything like that and I
drink water and maybe I'll drink Pepsi
if I feel then I need some energy some
sugar
so uh yeah of course it gives them big
advantage and match it like that well
there's so many Filipinos came over here
and robbed everybody it was uh amazing
and the best version of that is Efren
when Ephron first came over here he had
a fake name
oh really yeah yeah yeah Efren when he
first came over here
God damn it what was his name
it was like a Spanish name
see if you can find it so he played his
very first tournament under a fake name
because he is God I can't believe I
can't remember it generally I can
remember it
but he played under a fake name because
even though it was like the 1980s he
assumed that someone had been to the
Philippines and knew that this guy was
the king over there and then can you
find it
I'm looking a lot the efren's just
Google Google Efrin played under a fake
name Susan Morales Caesar Morales that's
it so that was his name so he came over
here under Caesar Morales and robbed
everybody and then uh when he came back
he was Efren Reyes and everybody's like
oh we got [ __ ] there it is Cesar
Morales stuns the field at Reds wow and
this was back when he was playing with a
five dollar pool cue
it does look like him but I don't think
it is because Dennis is uh quite a bit
older yeah younger younger rather than
that guy but that was in Houston and
what year is that 85 1985. yeah so he
came out stuns the field they [ __ ] came
over here and [ __ ] everybody up they
had no idea that he would go on to be
the greatest of all time Wade crane Wade
crane was a bad [ __ ] Dave
Matlock look at all these guys
yeah Mike guliasi wow
interesting Bobby Hunter Danny deliberto
all those names
yeah Wade crane also had a a fake name
he called himself Billy Johnson
yeah Billy Johnson was Wade Crane's Road
name well when the internet wasn't
around there was a big thing I think
yeah well that was his he would go
around playing as Billy Johnson because
everybody had heard of Wade Crane and so
he would just show up places and you
know people had no idea and then he
would Rob him it's perfect yeah well
there was a great book uh called playing
off the rail have you ever heard of that
book
playing off the rail was a book by this
guy David McCumber who at one point in
time was Hunter S Thompson's editor when
he was writing for a newspaper
um and wait and uh they took this guy
Tony anigone who was a really good Pro
and they went on the road with like
thirty five thousand dollars so like
like taped the money to his body and
[ __ ] in some places and they they did it
for a book the book is still available
you can still find the book somewhere
it's it's well worth it if you're a pool
player if you're into pool to get this
book because it's really David McCumber
is a really good writer it's really well
written and Tony anigone uh became a
friend of mine and I actually did
commentary with him once on a match back
in La back in the day and I became
friends with them and played with them a
bunch of times and uh tragically
think about a year and a half or so ago
he took his own life
he jumped off the Golden Gate Bridge
yeah very sad but in that book they went
to Chelsea Billiards they went to all
these different places where they they
hustled and they just set up matches and
set up games and played people
but it just gives you this kind of taste
especially because McCumber is such a
good writer it gives you this feeling
this really interested interesting like
depiction of what that life is like
these guys that do things like that like
you know Wade crane did when he called
himself Billy Johnson like that is a
whole subset of Americana where these
guys would travel around stay in shitty
hotels and gamble yeah I mean it's it's
kind of the same picture nowadays too
yeah there's still a lot of that oh yeah
yeah a lot it's
it's [ __ ] cool you know it's a it's a
really cool part of like this subculture
that people don't know about and I've
always admired people who did it I
always I always thought that was a cool
way to live your life it's a crazy
Reckless
but the people that did it they were
such [ __ ] characters they were such
interesting people yeah I mean all of
them it's it's a crazy lifestyle I don't
know if I would recommend it to my kids
but no but it's uh
I mean yeah maybe you would if if pool
becomes something really big you know if
pool does grow to the point where
there's million dollar purses absolutely
but not the gambling side you know I
went through I went through a lot of a
lot of that and uh
it's Shady did you ever get in a
situation where people pulled out guns
or people were robbing people no but my
friend did in Philippines what happened
once well he beat the god of a small
amount of money and uh the guy didn't
want to pay him
and he was he wasn't even like pushing
him to pay it was like 100 bucks
uh but uh he was the only foreign in the
in the building and he had the guy with
him that took care of him and kind of
made games for him and that guy started
saying something in Tagalog in
Philippines in their own language
and the guy pulled his gun and like
started shooting in in the air like
trying to say that I'm not playing here
he was like an authority
or something for a hundred bucks
I mean I just want to do for 51 000
gambling junkies yeah that's the thing
gambling junkies it's not about the
money for him right and there's so many
of those guys that are connected to
underworld characters there's all these
you know wild gamblers that are they're
almost all at least one step removed
from criminals yeah yeah if they're not
criminals themselves they might have a
criminal who's a backer
yeah I mean there is a lot of drug money
involved I think in the in gambling oh
yeah oh yeah there was always guys that
were backing people back in my day when
I was hanging around New York where
there were there were just these guys
that were drug addicts or drug dealers
they were selling Coke yeah and they had
that money and that was how they burned
the money they would come in and gamble
it yeah do the same thing tomorrow yeah
I remember one time we went to Harlem
to play this guy because these pimps
they would have a ton of money and they
would play Big Money one pocket and so
we went down to Harlem and here I am
this dorky fresh I was your age I was
like dude that's hanging around in
Harlem in this like [ __ ] heavy duty
like like hardcore pool room where these
pimps would go and gamble big money and
they'd come in with flashy clothes on
and it was just such a scene man it was
such a scene it was so cool it was just
so well just to sit there I mean I
wasn't playing those guys I sucked but I
was with my friend Johnny and this guy
Mount Vernon Tommy who was like a real
top player from the area and they were
all and this guy Juan who's also this
killer and they would we would all go
down together we'd take this drive down
together to Harlem and at the time
the garbage workers were on strike so
all the garbage was stacked outside so
when they would take garbage out to the
curb nobody would throw the garbage out
so there was six foot high piles of
garbage that lined the whole street not
bullshitting so you'd walk down the
sidewalk and rats would be everywhere I
mean everywhere you'd see the garbage
bags moving they would scramble in front
of your feet I'm like oh my God like I
grew up in the suburbs of Newton
Massachusetts right that's where I went
to high school
and I was in this like very nice you
know upper middle class neighborhoods
fresh face little cute kid and I'm
wandering around with these degenerate
gamblers in a a pool hall in Harlem
filled with pimps
wow but I got out of there and I
wouldn't trade those experiences for the
world because they were so it was so
interesting to see that the subculture
of these gamblers and pool players and
all they cared about was like who's the
killer like who's the guy you know and
they all had these crazy names and
everybody had these cool nicknames names
yeah oh my God it was it was such an
amazing time but it's such
that's what scares me about is that like
I think it's like it has it's right now
it's got like we said there's a
Resurgence but there was a time where I
thought this could go away